ده الولايات المتحده تخوض معركه صعبه ضد
الثلوج فالبلاد تواجه عاصفه ثلجيه
الجليديه قويه قادمه من القطب الشمالي تعد
الاقوى منذ حوالي اربعه عقود عاصفه كلفت
امريكا خسائر في الارواح والممتلكات
وتسببت في وفاه ما لا يقل عن 19 شخصا حتى
الان كما ادت العاصفه الثلجيه الى انقطاع
الكهرباء عن اكثر من سبع مئه الف شخص وبتت
انظمه الطاقه تعاني بسبب زياده الاستهلاك
الاضرار مستت بشكل كبير رحلات الطيران حيث
ادت العاصفه الى الغائها اكثر من
1300 رحله جويه في انحاء الولايات المتحده
وتاخر خمسه الاف وثلاث مئه رحله اخرى
[موسيقى]
من رونالدو
في الولايات المتحده معا حسينه مراسل
العربيه حسين اهلا بك معنا يعني عواصف
ثلجيه وبرد استثنائي في ربما اسوا عاصفه
تضرب الولايات المتحده منذ حوالي 40 سنه
ما الذي تمكنت من رصده حتى الان
تحيه لك صهيب انا هنا الان في مطار رونالد
ريجن في الحقيقه الاوضاع افضل بكثير من
اليومين السابقين اللذان يسبقان ليله
الذبله ليله عيد الميلاد المجيد من من نحو
والغاء لرحلات جويه يوم الجمعه من يوم
نتحدث هنا في مطار رونالدو
صغر المطار هو المطار المحاذي للعاصمه
واشنطن في مطارات اخرى الوضع يختلف نسيمه
في المطارات الكبيره
الرحلات المتوجهه نحو الولايات الشماليه
التي ضربها همم هذا الانفجار القطبي كما
يوصف خاصه منطقه غرب ولايه نيويورك
وتحديدا ااه مدينه بافلو- يجاورها الذي
تعرضت الى العاصفه الاسوء وهي وهنا
المفارقه ان هذه المدينه صهيب يا مدينه
مجهزه لمواجهه العواصف الكبيره لديهما
الادوات ولديهما الامكانيات لمواجهه كذا
عواصف ولكن مع ذلك هذه العاصفه كانت اقوى
من كل التجهيزات التي كانت سابقا نحن هنا
اذا سنتجول قليلا الاوضاع تبدو هادئه
اليوم مقارنه كما قلنا باليومين السابقين
حيث اضطر العديده من المسافرين الى البقاء
في المطار او همم حجز فنادق في منطقه
قريبه اليوم الرحلات كانت همم اسهل بسبب
طبعا تحسن الاجواء نوعا ما مقارنه بين
الماضيين اليوم همم على الصعيد الوطني تم
الغاء همم نحو 1600 رحله وتم تاجيل همم
نحو ثلاثه
رحله همم هنا في داخل المتحده همم سالنا
بعض الاشخاص هنا تحدثناهم طبعا هناك همم
حالات احباط الكثيرون هنا في الولايات
المتحده خلال هذه العطله للقضاء همم عط
عيد الميلاد ولا سينما ليله عيد الميلاد
ويوم عيد الميلاد العشاء والغداء مع
اقربائهم الكثير منهم تروا
البقاء في المطارات او بعضهم قرر يعني ان
يستاجر سياره ويسافر بالبر ولكن ايضا كان
هناك مخاطر بسبب الجديد الذي اصاب الطرقات
في العديد من الولايات هنا نسيمه في
الولايات
الوسطى التي ايضا لم تضربها العاصفه
الثلجيه ولكن البرد القارس الذي ادى الى
ااه هطول الامطار جليديه والى تكون طبقه
جلديه على الطرق في العديد منها